what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are getting into the
aftermath of secret Empire and god I'm
going into the weekend I'm loafing this
weekend I am I'm not really gonna do
anything if it doesn't require me to I'm
gonna watch Netflix I'm gonna clean up
my house I'm gonna have a good weekend I
don't know maybe like cook some really
nice dinners or something like that but
secret Empire admittedly has been one of
the most divisive stories that I've ever
read in the history of comics I mean I
was there when like the Clone Saga was
spider-man but I was there when that
whole thing happened and like it was
interesting to see but it was really
more of like Fanta Spider Man it wasn't
like a split in the Marvel community and
it's been nuts to watch this whole thing
unfold but whenever we would do
character explanations and we would talk
about stories it would split the Marvel
community you guys are living through
this in real time now people are more
vocal now than they've ever been because
they have Twitter and Facebook and
YouTube channels like mine and so on and
so forth but the idea here is that this
story just really created a rift in the
community and it was crazy but if you
have you not had a chance to see my
secret empire videos I highly recommend
that you go check them out just for the
sake of understanding everything that's
going on but the idea shield had created
a cosmic cube the Cosmic Cube had become
sentient and the result was that the
Cosmic Cube was taken over by the Red
Skull and it was taught to believe in
hydras ideologies in response to this at
the request of the Red Skull the Cosmic
Cube altered though the reality of
Captain America Steve Rogers it altered
its past too in order to make it out the
Steve Rogers was a Hydra agent and so
witness altered reality what Steve
Rogers began to do was go through and
basically implement his plan to allow
Hydra to take over the United States
setting his sights on the world and then
using the Cosmic Cube to take over the
entire universe now of course this led
to this hunt for the Cosmic Cube in the
sense of the cubed basically been
shattered and it was literally just this
chase to find all these different shards
but what Marvel also gave us was an out
they gave us something called the
vanishing point and what we ended up
learning was that with the Cosmic Cube
becoming sentient it also became
terrified of what the world was like
with Hydra ruling it and so what the
Cosmic Cube did is a create of the
vanishing point as a place where the
memory of these various superheroes
specifically Captain America with how he
used to be was basically held and so
what ended up happening is that at the
end of secret Empire this memory
was given a physical body and this
basically was the return of classic
Captain America and so classic Captain
America fought against Hydra Captain
America and the classic version won and
so in the aftermath of this this story
picks up well essentially what amounts
to a healing process the idea that the
world is rebuilding but the coolest
thing about this is that this focuses on
the question who was right in secret
Empire and how did things transpire did
they transpire the way that we think
they did or are we not remembering it
correctly and that's the crazy thing
because there is this prison that was
created within the realm of the of the
Marvel Universe Elisa's prison as is
called the shadow pillar now shadow
pillar basically seems to be the
Florence Colorado Supermax now for those
of you guys who don't know here in the
real world Florence Colorado is home to
a supermax prison where people spend 23
hours out of the day in solitary
confinement they get one hour to
basically go out and do their own thing
but it's housed the most violent
individuals in the world like Timothy
McVeigh for example after blowing the
Federal Building in half at Oklahoma
City
he was housed in Florence Colorado until
he was executed so again there's all
these different things you know with
regards to the comparisons between
Marvel and the real world but there's
only one occupant of the shadow pillar
prison and that's Hydra Captain America
now of course the classic version goes
to see him and this is probably one of
the greatest conversations in the
history of Marvel Comics it's so cool
the way this unfolds because it's the
question who was really right here now
the funny thing is that witness
conversation initially opens this really
just Hydra cap saying I know why you're
here like you're here for maybe some
kind of indication you're here to
basically say hey look you know yeah man
I was right you were wrong but the funny
thing about this is that Hydra cap makes
the point in basically saying I didn't
break any laws I didn't do anything
illegal and that's the funny thing about
this is because remember it when he rose
to power it's not like he walked in to
the United States with an army of Hydra
agents assassinated the president wiped
out Congress destroyed the Preem court
it wasn't a Handmaid's Tale and the rise
of the sons of Jacob it was him coming
in and actually being given that power
and with that absolute authority he
conquered the United States he was asked
to be director of shield he was given
the position given that power by an
external source he never actually
conquered anyone he never actually
killed anyone in terms of you know his
role or as his rise to power and that's
what makes this so cool is because in
the face of this classic Captain America
as well we'll end up finding you
accountable anyway and Hydra Captain
America's response is yeah because I'm
not a friend and this is really cool
because myself and comic story and we're
talking about this and he's starting a
secret a secret Empire coverage and you
guys should definitely check it out but
we were running and we're running over
this whole thing and that's the crazy
thing about it is because Hydra Captain
America is not wrong if we look at the
various characters who have gone through
and who have engaged in actions that
have resulted in the loss of life you
have characters like magneto who stood
trial for his actions but Magneto's not
an Avenger The Scarlet Witch Quicksilver
they were both Avengers they've done
some pretty heinous things and they were
never held accountable Captain America
is one of these guys who protects his
own and that's the reason why this is
such a great big huge debate is because
the whole argument the whole point that
Hydra Captain America makes here is
you're a guy who protects the people
that you agree with you protect the
people that you like you don't protect
the people that you don't like not only
that it's also this equation being
dragged in of what's the world like now
is the world really a better place
because in this instance what Hydra
Captain America says is look I was
literally trying to make the world
better
I saw this perfect world where there was
no war I saw this perfect world where
there was no panic there was no chaos
there was no famine there were no snow
children starving in the streets there
were no people robbing banks in order to
make sure they could provide their own
that none of that stuff was there I saw
a perfect world and then you came along
and you took it you took it away and you
basically returned the world back to the
way that it used to be and what he ends
up saying is you may believe that you've
won but you haven't won because Hydra
had this perfect world for a brief
moment in time those who were loyal to
Hydra saw this perfect reality and the
result is that when you took it away
they are now all the more desperate it's
tantamount to going to a starving man
giving him a sandwich letting him have
one bite and then taking the sandwich
away he'll do almost anything to get it
back in order to satiate that hunger
that's aching him so bad and so the
ultimate argument here is that Hydra is
gonna be more desperate now than they've
ever been because they want that world
that they saw for a brief glimpse in
time now what this also does that
transitions for a second two characters
like the Punisher and it's kind of cool
here because with the Punisher because
of the fact that he basically says look
I followed Hydra Captain America because
he was Captain America then once it was
revealed that Hydra Captain America was
basically a bad guy that Punisher
basically sort of turncoat it ended up
going back to his
away and just killing everybody who was
Hydra but that's the funny thing about
this is because until classic Captain
America showed up there was no reason
for Punisher to believe that Hydra
Captain America and classic Captain
America were two different people now
remember this is not new and the
original civil war story the one of the
things that Marvel solidified is that
Frank Castle fought in the Vietnam War
because he wanted to be like Captain
America Frank Castle idolizes Captain
America and so because of that whatever
Captain America does Frank castle will
go along with it and so again it's
really a funny situation because one of
the things that I noticed with regards
to the comments on secret Empire is a
lot of people were like no way Punisher
would join Hydra Captain America but he
would because the actions of Hydra
Captain America fall perfectly in line
with what Frank Castle does Frank Castle
doesn't go around to like food banks and
like donate money he just goes around
and kills criminals wherever he finds
them so he really is in a lot of ways
exactly what it was that Hydra was
fighting for at the time the other half
of this is the question of did classic
Steve Rogers make the world better by
setting things the way they used to be
under the rule of Hydra sure superheroes
were killed and sure in humans were
basically tossed in camps but people
were not afraid of their neighbors
people could leave their doors unlocked
at night because they knew that
everybody was too scared to break in
through their homes
nobody committed any crimes whatsoever
because the hammer of Hydra came down
fast and it came down swift and so
because of this with classic Steve
Rogers setting things back to the way
they used to be now people go back to
being scared again people go back to
being fearful of their neighbors where
people didn't have poverty where we
didn't have homelessness because Hydra
provided everybody with everything they
needed
well then suddenly people are cashed
back down into homelessness people are
cast back down into poverty governmental
corruption will run rampant once again
money will be the defining factor on
what it is that makes a person
worthwhile the world is not better than
it was but notice this this is the exact
same argument that we had when it came
to injustice the question is is it worth
giving up everything is it worth people
basically living in fear of their
government in place of living in fear of
their neighbor is that a sacrifice that
people are willing to make and those are
the opposing dichotomies of these two
guys as they argue as they debate that's
what they're talking about the question
is who came out on top here is
world a better place because of the fact
that it's the way that it used to be and
this instance Hydra Captain America
basically says at least I was honest
about what I was at least I came forward
and said I am an agent of Hydra at least
I came forward and I launched the entire
campaign and I told people if you commit
crimes you will be dealt with harshly I
was the government operating in order to
ensure a safer and secure America with
classic Captain America and with the
Avengers it's not that way remember that
was the whole basis behind the champions
the champions joined up they they formed
their own group because they were tired
of seeing the Avengers go into local
towns go into communities fight these
villains and then just walk off and say
okay everything's cool now when people
were watching their livelihoods come
crashing down when they were watching
the homes they built destroyed because
the Avengers were going through and
fighting villains and then the Avengers
just leave the people looked to Hydra as
an alternative that people welcomed
Hydra because in the face of the Hydra
rule sure it was dark it was dystopian
but it also kept them safe and secure
didn't have to worry about their home is
being destroyed because the Avengers
were fighting some villain and when the
fight was finished the Avengers just
left and at the same time no one
appointed Captain America as a protector
of the country it's not like the
Avengers or a government-sanctioned
superhero team the Avengers just formed
one day people will basically be a lot
of them and said yeah sure like we love
them being here we love you know we love
them protecting us but the argument of
Hydra Captain America is what's the
difference between what you did and what
I did because people celebrated me too
people said yeah hydras keeping us
protected the actions of the Avengers
the x-men the maximum security storyline
the onslaught saga all this has
basically been these massive calamities
because superheroes chose that they were
going to be the protectors and in the
aftermath of these conflicts they dusted
their hands they said yes the good guys
winning they patted themselves on the
back they went to the bar they had a
beer and they thought nothing of the
people who were being affected that was
never their concerned you didn't see the
Avengers rebuilding people's homes he
didn't see the Avengers funding
individual people who lost their
livelihood because the business they
worked out was destroyed during a
conflict you didn't see that and so in
this instance Hydra Captain America says
we're basically the same thing you're
vigilantes you appointed yourselves as
protectors you do whatever you feel you
need to do in order to keep the country
protected you protect
your own you protect Avengers because
they're your friends I do the exact same
thing so what's the difference now the
other side of this argument is classic
Captain America comes along and says
because you imprison innocent people
because you took people who you deemed
to be the enemy and you threw him in
jail because you didn't like what they
did you went through back-alley deals
you lied you were duplicitous you
tricked people and you used my face to
do it and that's the huge crux of this
argument when shield gave Hydra Captain
America absolute power they didn't know
they were giving it to a Hydra agent
otherwise they never would have they
thought they were giving it to classic
Captain America who had fought alongside
the United States for years and years
and years and years that's the
difference here is that yes Hydra
Captain America made the country safer
but at the end of the day he was
sacrificing all the wrong things to do
it the argument the classic Captain
America makes here is the same argument
that I made well after I was done
playing devil's advocate about Batman
but it was the argument that I made
towards the tail into the video which
you can find over a comic story and on
the RnB ii podcast and we were arguing
injustice sure the world is imperfect
sure there are terrible things that
happen to good people and there are good
things that happen to bad people the
difference between some totalitarian
fascist regime imposing its own will and
his own order and people who were
allowed to explore their own order and
their own will means that people under
the role of freedom are allowed to get
better they were allowed to look at the
way things used to be and say we don't
want to be there anymore we don't want
to cross that bridge anymore we don't
want to be in a world where we're afraid
of our neighbors we don't want to be in
a world where we have to rob in order to
feed ourselves or our children we want
to live in a world where we don't have
to worry about those kinds of things and
so because of that it's Hydra Captain
America saying yes you instilled order
but it only would have lasted for so
long you're not going to live forever
and even if you were an enlightened
dictatorship even if you were benign in
terms of how you dealt with the average
person who's to say the next person who
took over your role would be the same
and so the idea here is that in a free
society people have the ability to
better their own laws that's the
importance of it people have the ability
to evolve to grow to eventually move
beyond individual desires and wants and
think about what's best for the society
and that's the argument that classic
Captain America makes and so again we're
not really given a resolution on who's
right or who's wrong we're just kind of
told these are the
humans that are out there and so what is
up happening is ultimately with the yard
showing up and with Cossack Captain
America leading we end up finding out
that Hydra Captain America's rut was
right when he said hydras everywhere
Hydra will never go away because we end
up finding out that one of these prison
guards is a Hydra agent when he says
hail Hydra indicating that at some point
along the line Hydra Captain America
will probably be let loose but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob port if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you